no no
[Música]
a escala en parís ayuda palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
la crisis mundial de el coronavirus es
un síntoma de una crisis más profunda de
nuestro sistema económico esta es una de
las preguntas a las que intenta
responder nuestro invitado de hoy el
historiador francés de bombas es
bienvenido a escala en parís bueno dios
bueno este test profesor en la
universidad autónoma de chiapas en san
cristóbal de las casas en mexico ha
escrito varios libros de historia
medieval y también la rebelión zapatista
o adiós al capitalismo ahora acaba de
publicar vasquismo publicado por la
editorial francesa la de kubert que se
podría traducir como basculaciones o
giros o inclinaciones en mundos
emergentes posibles deseables y es un
libro que escribió en plena pandemia de
a virus y contrariamente a los que
defienden la existencia de la colapso
logía que es como el derrumbe total de
nuestro mundo del sistema como si
nuestro planeta estuviera en fase
terminal usted propone otra tesis con
más incertidumbre la de esos giros las
de esas basculaciones que provocan
derrumbes parciales de nuestro sistema
capitalista y que la pandemia que
estamos viviendo es uno de los síntomas
no de esos giros en un sistema el
capitalista que dice que está en una
crisis estructural en qué consiste en
esos giros esas basculaciones la idea es
que a partir de una situación de
aparente equilibrio pero que en realidad
es muy inestable pues las cosas fueran
bascular hacia un lado o hacia otro y
que efectivamente a partir de esa
situación se pueden dar giros
muy importantes y hasta brutales en
cierta dirección pero también en otra o
sea y lo que quiero resaltar es el
carácter inestable del mundo en el cual
estamos
vivimos en un mundo cada vez más
inestable todo lo que parece estable en
realidad es fundamentalmente inestable y
por lo tanto imprevisible y entonces es
esa apertura de las posibilidades que
quiero resaltar y efectivamente con la
experiencia de la crisis del coronavirus
y el confinamiento mundial que se ha
dado a raíz de esto y el económico el
paro económico de todo lo que hemos
vivido pues es una experiencia vivida
por casi toda la humanidad de esta
basculación digamos es decir de un giro
brutal en unos días o sea en unos días
hemos pasado en una realidad a la que
nadie estaba preparado inesperada
y con realidades que nadie se podía
esperar y que como todo el mundo por
sorpresa y que nos proyectó en unos días
en una realidad profundamente diferente
a todo lo que habíamos conocido
anteriormente eso es un ejemplo vivido a
escala mundial y planetaria por por
miles de millones de seres humanos al
mismo momento
es tan frágil no finalmente la
fragilidad efectivamente en la economía
mundial que parecía pues ahí con tener
un poder y una
una organización muy muy estable pues se
dio que en unos días pues pudo quedar
paralizada totalmente por un factor así
tan ínfimo como es un virus como el del
sars con dos usted sostiene en el libro
que la pandemia el coronavirus forma
parte de un fenómeno mayor más global la
multiplicación reciente de zoonosis que
son buenos
cuando los virus de los animales pasan
al hombre culpa a la ganadería intensiva
o al monocultivo sin embargo lo que
sabemos hasta ahora es que justamente
ser virus sale de un murciélago que es
un animal salvaje en wuhan en china
entonces bueno
hay dos cosas la primera es que las
causas el proceso de desarrollo hacia la
humanidad del sars scott 2 el virus del
que nos preocupa ahora en red no se sabe
nada lo único seguro efectivamente es
que proviene del murciélago pero el
canal no se sabe absolutamente nada las
misiones de la o ms pues no han podido
investigar en china hay un bloqueo
informativo no sabemos nada en este caso
hay varias tesis pero pero no se sabe
absolutamente nada lo que sí se sabe es
la la causalidad de las zoonosis
emergentes y aquí el hecho de que estas
nuevas son o si es es decir enfermedades
que pasan de los animales al ser humano
se han multiplicado tremendamente desde
los años 1980 y más aún desde digamos el
inicio del siglo 21 está el sars 1 el
merced el cica el ébola etcétera
etcétera ahí hay muchos más que nosotros
y como no
especialistas en esto ni conocemos la
culpa de lo no cultivo y es un fenomenal
adhería intensiva es un fenómeno
indudable es una emergencia reciente de
este tipo de enfermedades infecciosas
virales en las causas es algo muy
importante del cual nunca se habla casi
nunca se habla
en todo lo que se desee tenemos un año
de hablar del coronavirus s se habla de
las medidas que se toman de las que no
se toman de los variantes etcétera pero
nunca se habla de la cuestión de las
causas y en las causas hay muchos
especialistas que insisten en que hay
una causalidad humana es decir por la
actividad humana por la actividad
económica del sistema económica que
tenemos actualmente y hay factores
específicos en particular uno es la
destrucción del medio ambiente
selvático en donde viven los animales
salvajes y al destruir por ejemplo
mediante la deforestación esos los
lugares donde viven esos animales por
ejemplo los murciélagos pues se
desplazan y se acercan más a los lugares
donde viven los humanos y eso es un
factor de transmisión hacia la humanidad
y el otro factor son las mega granjas de
donde sé dónde
mega granjas de puercos y de pollos en
particular que son como brotes de
infección muy peligrosos bueno eso son
miles y miles decenas de miles de
animales que viven ahí amontonados y son
brotes de infección que también
favorecen el paso de esos virus de los
animales a la que quería preguntar bueno
la pandemia de coronavirus según usted
es una señal de alerta por esa expansión
económica pero tan mal lo hemos hecho
los humanos el progreso porque ahora
pues hay menos hambruna que hace unos
años la edad media de la gente o sea la
gente morimos mucho más tarde usar tan
mal el progreso es tan malo o se puede
hacer de diferente manera
bueno ahí por ejemplo
no se trata de negar obviamente
y que haya algunos avances que haya
avances importantes sí claro la
esperanza de vida se duplicó desde el
siglo 19 hasta hoy bueno también con
muchas de muchas desigualdades entre los
países aunque son muy importantes y
también entre ricos y pobres pero bueno
si hay avances de la medicina que han
permitido esto eso es obvio no no hay
que negar esto pero al mismo tiempo
podemos observar que el sistema
económico en el cual vivimos le vamos a
dar su nombre es el capitalismo también
es el sistema más yo voy a decir esto
más patógeno que haya existido en la
historia es decir claro por un lado la
medicina pudo controlar y resolver
muchos problemas de salud pero al mismo
tiempo no no ha existido ninguna otra
sociedad en el pasado que ha generado
tantas enfermedades como el sistema
actual
contaminación atmosférica que provoca
cientos de miles de muertos cada año
productos tóxicos como pesticidas que
provocan cánceres alimentación
industrial que provoca diabetes
hipertensión sobrepeso obesidad
el modo de vida moderna que moderno que
provoca estrés depresión etcétera
también el sistema les provoca
enfermedades como nunca no sabemos
creando también una generación de
angustiados porque parece como si todo
fuera muy mal cuando hay bueno mucho
progreso y hay jóvenes que parecen
angustia dijimos por esta situación no
estamos creando una generación realmente
de depresivos con estos mensajes pero
bueno yo creo que no es esto que provoca
la depresión la depresión ya está ahí
hay una un consumo de productos para
quitarse la depresión el estrés que
nunca se ha visto antes claro podríamos
cerrar los ojos y para no para no
angustiarnos y decir pues no existe ni
el comida ni el cambio climático y así
nos vamos felices y sin angustiarnos
pero la cuestión no es no angustiarnos o
no angustiarnos la cuestión es que la
realidad es una realidad que si no
hacemos nada pues van a haber nuevas
pandemias va a seguir el cambio
climático con una destrucción
ambiente y un cambio de las condiciones
de la vida humana y no humana en la
tierra que va a provocar cada vez más
catástrofes eso es todo esto se está
dando al final bueno usted recuerda una
cita al final del libro de fredric
jameson que dice es más fácil imaginar
el fin del mundo que el fin del
capitalismo usted la rebate no es a esa
cita pero por ejemplo
con el ejemplo del coronavirus y de la
crisis que todo iba a cambiar que iba a
haber nuevas formas de solidaridad
durante la pandemia ese era el mensaje y
finalmente le voy a dar ejemplo de las
vacunas aquí ha sido el el más fuerte el
que ha conseguido más más vacunas el que
ha pagado más las ha tenido primero
incluso en europa vídeo carestía de
vacunas por eso él realmente cree que es
posible entrar en una era post
capitalista como usted defiende es uno
de los posibles por eso esa idea de
basculamiento que a partir de una
estamos en una situación de crisis
sistémica y justamente todo lo que
provoca el cambio climático esa era de
las pandemias en la cual estamos
entrando la del coronavirus no
desafortunadamente es probable que no
sea la última entonces todas esas
situaciones que van a generar crisis
cada vez más fuertes pues abren
posibilidades que las cosas pueden ir
osea seguir en el mismo camino
obviamente con el coronavirus no hubo un
cambio mágico de pasar a un mundo
totalmente diferente sigue el mismo
mundo pero hay inflexiones importantes
puede haber esa transición hacia un
capitalismo verde es una posibilidad que
no resolvería todos los problemas pero
quizás por lo menos y entre esos
posibles efectivamente la la crisis es
tan grave y real no es una imaginación
nada más para angustiarnos es una
realidad que eso también puede abrir las
posibilidades que los mundos no
capitalistas que ya están emergiendo en
algunos lugares específicos pues se
vayan multiplicando y abriendo una
posibilidad para la humanidad
de esas que nos liberaría de un sistema
económico depredador en particular de la
naturaleza y que es la causa de muchas
de las cosas que estamos sufriendo
muchísimas gracias
llegó más base por haber venido hasta
nuestros estudios autor del libro va
escribo le deseamos mucho éxito gracias
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com bien france24 puntocom
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]